hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown the corona virus
pandemic has raised plenty of questions
about the us's relationship with China
John DeMars assistant attorney general
for national security
joins host Jessica Rosenthal to discuss
how the Department of Justice is
pursuing economic espionage and
intellectual property theft cases
against the Chinese over the past five
weeks 26 million Americans have filed
for unemployment and many of them have
yet to receive any benefits Wall Street
Journal economics reporter Sarah Cheney
chats with host Dave Anthony about why
folks are having a hard time receiving
government assistance and what is being
done to alleviate the problem Plus
commentary from Fox News correspondent
at-large Geraldo Rivera the Fox News
rundown is a Daily News podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player by going to
Fox News podcasts dot-com I'm Tammy
Bruce i'm juan williams i'm shannon
bream and this is the fox news rundown
[Music]
Wednesday April 29th 2020
I'm Jessica Rosenthal the virus pandemic
has prompted a lot of finger-pointing
including at China and the country's
reaction is not surprising to those
who've been prosecuting them for years
it's crystallizing a lot of the problems
that we've already seen right it's
crystallizing you know the continued
theft of intellectual property
biomedical research I'm Dave Anthony 26
million Americans have filed for
unemployment the past five weeks and
many of them are frustrated they have
gotten no money yet this was an
unprecedented event it would be hard
under really any circumstance four
states state labor departments to be
fully prepared to process this number of
claims and I'm Geraldo Rivera I've got
the final word on the Fox News rundown
[Music]
everything has an origin story but when
it comes to the kovat 19 virus that
story is fraught with suspicion and
blame it came from China specifically
the city of Wuhan but once we get past
that fact things get more complicated
there are accusations that China knew
far more about the virus than they let
on there are questions about how the
World Health Organization handled the
information they were receiving from the
Chinese I'm instructing my
administration to halt funding of the
World Health Organization while a review
is conducted to assess the World Health
Organization's role and severely
mismanaging and covering up the spread
of the corona virus everybody knows
what's going on there but when it comes
to China and any consequences they
should face the president takes a more
wait-and-see approach if they were
knowingly responsible certainly if they
did if it was a mistake a mistake is a
mistake but if they were knowingly
responsible yeah then there should be
consequences some Republican senators
have introduced legislation to strip the
Chinese government of sovereign immunity
allowing Americans to sue in US courts
US Senator Tom cotton told Sean Hannity
earlier this month if it's not a mistake
the Chinese Communist Party is
responsible for every single death every
job lost every retirement nest egg lost
from this coronavirus president Trump
has questioned China's case numbers and
death toll and insists he's been tougher
on China than anyone they made a
statement that our soldiers brought it
into China came from China and you know
we just signed a very big deal with
China they're paying us a lot of money
in tariffs and other things they never
paid us ten cents of China's take
advantage of the United States until I
came here before the pandemic most of
the Trump administration's China talk
involved the lingering trade war with
the US and president Trump alternated
between touting his relationship with
Chinese President Xi Jinping and calling
out China for unfair trade practices
whether that was over producing product
dumping product non-tariff barriers in
August of 2017 the President signed an
order today I'm directing the United
State
it's trade representative to examine
China's policies practices and actions
with regard to the force transfers of
American technology and the theft of
American intellectual property less than
a year later the government began to
pursue China more heavily through
another Avenue the Justice Department
career federal prosecutors formed what
they called the do J's China initiative
and they've been pursuing economic
espionage and IP theft cases against the
Chinese
ever since the more we look at Chinese
activities around the world in reaction
to the corona virus the clearer it
becomes that they're acting consistent
with all of the malign activities that
we were seeing before John Demers is the
assistant attorney general of the
Justice Department's National Security
Division and he's the head of the OJS
China initiative so for instance we see
a number of computer intrusions against
healthcare facilities against research
entities again this universities all of
which are doing work on coronavirus and
if you think about it it would be crazy
to think that after spending years
stealing biomedical research and
intellectual property the Chinese would
taken a hiatus when it comes to the most
high-profile biomedical research at this
time and the reason for that is that not
only does that information or Mike that
information have great commercial value
but also it will have tremendous
geopolitical value if China can say and
and if it is the first to develop a
vaccine in addition we also see the
Chinese and others like the Russians and
the Iranians but the Chinese looking to
spread disinformation about the virus
also for geopolitical purposes that is
to position themselves better as the
leaders in the world and as having a
system in the world that works better to
protect their citizens than does
liberal democracy the one that we live
in and Europe I would imagine to I mean
I mean you're absolutely mommy or
Democratic Republic right would the DOJ
have any interest or capability really
in pursuing any sort of investigation
regarding the virus well in terms of the
activities that I was talking about and
without obviously commenting on any
particular investigation the areas that
interest us the most are covert foreign
influence activity so that is when the
Chinese are trying to project or again
the Russians are trying to project a
message about the virus and not being
open about the fact that they the
government are doing it we certainly
have seen statements that are
disinformation but are openly on the
part of the Chinese government that's
not something that we pursue as an
investigative matter that's the
diplomatic matter that's for my State
Department than others but for us our
focus is covert disinformation and of
course as I mentioned that you know
investigations that may involve any of
the computer intrusions that were seen
well and you've headed up the the
initiative right that the DOJ is
initiative for the past mine initiative
for the past two years and obviously we
that's an initiative focused on you know
economic espionage stealing you know
trade raid theft tell me a little bit
about about that and why it really only
started two years ago we've we've known
that China's been stealing our stuff of
a better term for much longer than that
right yes no we definitely have and in
fact the first Justice Department
charges against the Chinese were back in
2014 but we started it more formally a
couple of years ago really as an
outgrowth of the intelligence that the
then Attorney General and I were seeing
on a daily basis from the FBI and from
other parts of the intelligence
community and how much we were seeing of
intellectual property theft either by
Chinese actors or even by the government
itself and the question that he asked me
and we asked ourselves is well what can
we
helped to do about this problem and so
we put together this initiative which
was meant to focus us that the main
justice department and also focused the
94 US Attorney's Office and all of the
FBI field offices on this problem of
Chinese economic espionage messaging
that it is in fact a priority for us
despite the fact that these cases can be
very difficult they can involve
intelligence information which can
complicate matters if you're trying to
make that into law enforcement evidence
and you know the numbers that an office
will bring in any given year aren't
gonna be astronomical but we wanted a
message that this is where we wanted the
department to put its resources and to
focus on this behavior the second part
was really to reach out to the private
sector and to academics and to encourage
them to work with us because this is not
a problem where the government is being
targeted in this area it's a problem
where the private sector and academic
institutions are being targeted and
therefore we're not gonna solve it
without their cooperation and help you
guys ramped up this initiative as the
administration was pretty hyper focused
on a trade deal with China and I'm
wondering because we you know we heard
administration officials including the
president talk often about trade theft
IP theft and I'm wondering sort of how
that dovetailed with the creation of the
initiative was this was this initiative
almost like a way of saying you know
what world trade organizations and other
world bodies that are supposed to be
helping us out here you guys aren't you
guys aren't doing it we need to well it
was an effort to combat the theft of
intellectual property which as you said
is also an issue that's being addressed
in in the trade talks and as those trade
talks you know went well and went better
they've had their ups and downs over the
years you know we've continued on the
law enforcement side to press this issue
regardless of how those trade talks were
going because we see it as criminal
activity at the end of the day and
something that we need to address here
in this country especially in light of
the fact that many of our cases involve
insiders so yes
we have our cyber intrusion cases and
there's a fair amount of that activity
going on from China but many of these
cases that we've charged involved people
right here in the u.s. stealing their
employers intellectual property either
directly on behalf of the Chinese or in
the hopes of reselling it to the Chinese
or setting up a business over there so
that's something that needs to be
addressed regardless of how the the
trade talks go can we talk about the
Edward Penn case for a minute
it was the case out of San Francisco and
correct me if I'm wrong you guys I know
this predated the China initiative by
three years but the FBI threw a double
agent gave pang SD cards full of I'm
assuming fake information about the US
government to take back to Beijing that
seems like a very challenging way to go
to cultivate that relationship and then
getting the wrong information back to
the Chinese but it's also the kind of
thing I think Americans are hoping that
we're doing you share with us anything
that came from that case you know in the
in the in that relationship and then
getting the wrong information hopefully
to the Chinese well it's not a tactic
that's helpful yeah the the the case
itself obviously the charges you know
are more recent but the the
investigative activity had been going on
as you said for a number of years the
purpose of undertaking that kind of
investigative activity is to understand
and if in the first instance is to
understand how Chinese intelligence
officers are operating in the u.s.
because one thing we know is Chinese
intelligence officers don't want to come
to the u.s. because they realize that
they're at risk when they come here and
very vulnerable to the FBI so what kind
of networks are what kind of
arrangements do Chinese intelligence
officers use to try to get information
in that case it wasn't commercial
intellectual property it was the more
traditional SBI espionage information
what kind of arrangements do they use
what kind of you know what we call cut
outs do they use people who will be
couriers of that information what kind
of tradecraft in that case is fast
he sees some very old-school tradecraft
what we call dead drops right well one
person in this case goes to hotel room
puts the information leaves the hotel
room another person comes into the same
hotel room takes information leaves the
money leaves the other / you know the
two people never ever see each other
right and and learning how the Chinese
are operating is is the first purpose
and then the second is once you think
you've you know sort of learned
everything you can from that
investigation is to disrupt it right and
to make the jobs of those intelligence
officers harder but also that you know
at the same time see you know the
broader networks that may be being
developed by those intelligence officers
the kinds of businesses they like to
take advantage of to do that what do you
think this virus will will do to to to
our relationship with China what do you
think economic espionage theft of IP
will ramp up will slow down what do you
think what do you if you had the crystal
ball moment you know where do you see
this going yeah I mean it's
crystallizing a lot of the problems that
we've already seen right it's
crystallizing for us you know the
continued theft of intellectual property
biomedical research its crystallizing
China's increasingly muscular foreign
influence activity its crystallizing the
way that they use you know aid to push a
Chinese political agenda around the
world and so I think it's bringing a lot
of these problems into stark relief and
you know where this all goes will depend
on not just how we react but as you
pointed out how Europe reacts and how
other countries around the world react
well I think those are my questions US
Attorney General for Nationals assistant
US attorney general for national
security John Demers thank you so much
for your time
great thank you very much
this is Geraldo Rivera with your Fox
News commentary
coming up it's the big focus right now
after more than a month of social
distancing and many Americans stuck at
all there's a hunger for getting our
country back and it's happening but
President Trump is leading it up to
States on when to lift restrictions st.
testing will be key we want everyone to
be safe and I think you're seeing that
you think a lot of Governors get out and
they want to open it up but the damage
from all the shutdowns has been done
this is the biggest negative shock that
our economy I think has ever seen White
House economic adviser Kevin Hassett
after a tidal wave of layoffs in the
past five weeks more than 26 million
people have filed unemployment claims
think about that it's more than all the
jobs created in the u.s. in the last
decade since the Great Recession ended
my heart aches for the businessmen and
women who have not been able to work
looking at savings going down every day
Ohio Governor Mike DeWine is ready to
lift some restrictions in his State
Friday it's hard to believe how fast
this has all happened the coronavirus
was a distant far-off problem in China
in January now the US has more than a
million cases more than anywhere else in
the world wiping out an economy that was
strong and an unemployment rate that was
at 50-year lows before the coronavirus
led to widespread business shutdowns in
about mid-march we were seeing record
low levels of jobless claims you know
for at least a couple of years they were
around or just over 200,000 per week
Sarah Cheney is an economics reporter
for The Wall Street Journal there are
still lots of people who are trying to
apply for unemployment benefits but have
been unsuccessful just because a lot of
these states websites and call centers
are still overwhelmed there have been a
lot of people and a lot of stories
written and you certainly file followed
this that over the weeks of these
layoffs that have led
- these filings people aren't getting
paid and it's taking a while some people
have reported they make dozens of calls
a day and never get answers they get
rejected online or the website kicks
them off and then they have no
application that goes through so there's
a lot of frustration what is the problem
as they go across them in every state is
different but it seems like it's a lot
of states having the same issues this
was an unprecedented event it would be
hard under really any circumstance for
states state labor departments to be
fully prepared to process this number of
claims that said a lot of states have
very antiquated technology we're talking
you know computer systems that are 40
years old they're using you know relying
on code that is also decades old and so
these these antiquated systems are just
not you know set up to be nimble and to
handle this this sudden surge of claims
and is there an added issue where even
the people who work for the state to
process the claims are probably not in
the office either they're probably at
home dealing with technology just like
people who are filing are it would that
be true that's a good point some states
have definitely mentioned that it's you
know part of the whole transition
process has been figuring out how do we
operate within these sort of regulations
and you know new social distancing
guidelines and how many people could
they possibly have to answer phones when
you have millions of people trying to
call right so one thing that a lot of
states have been doing is adding on a
lot of staff or reallocating staff from
other other departments to help field
calls and and so I think that to some
extent that is that is helping but you
know when you're talking about a state
like New York where so many people have
been laid off and are trying to to file
frowning
women benefits you know staffing up can
only do so much now some of that
frustration that's being felt around the
country as millions of people still wait
for their unemployment checks
I haven't even received my stimulus
check so I've gone 30 days with zero
income Jennifer Bailey is a hairstylist
in Texas I just want people to think
about you know how long can you keep
your house and a business running off
your savings which you have in the bank
right now if somebody said right now you
will make no more money for 30 days it
was in March with her salon closed they
promised us because we're also employed
that we would get unemployment benefits
they talked about the PPP loans all of
those things what we've repeatedly been
denied for self-employment even though
we were supposed to be approved
according to the economic impact package
she's referencing that two trillion
dollar economic stimulus bill that
Congress approved which includes
enhanced unemployment assistance an
extra $600 a week to those out of work
in addition to the state benefits people
can collect it also allows people like
Jennifer Bailey who were self employed
to file or so-called gig workers or
freelancers who typically did not
qualify the guidance generally is that
if you're unsure just try to apply for
unemployment benefits the states make
the final call you have written about
how states don't have an unlimited
amount of unemployment money and some
might soon run out or an in danger of
doing that what happens when a state
doesn't have any more unemployment money
it's important to note that even when a
state runs out of its own state trust
fund money that pays out the the regular
unemployment benefits they can tap into
federal dollars they make a request to
the federal government for loans in the
last year after the last recession those
states were were on the hook to pay that
money back so even though they're likely
to take out a federal wellness
they're still responsible for paying it
back does Congress need to be in session
to approve alone for a state if it runs
out Congress doesn't need to approve any
of these additional federal loans to
replenish the state trust funds when
they run out of money a state's governor
just submits a letter to the federal
government asking for the funds okay so
the money just goes and so no States in
danger in this crisis of running out of
unemployment benefit money for all the
millions who've applied that's our
understanding right now yes now this
week small businesses were able to start
applying again for federal loans after
Congress replenished the empty fund if
those companies use a big portion of
that money to keep and pay their
employees the loans become grants that
don't have to be paid back Treasury
secretary Steve minuchin so the first
round impacted about 30 million workers
I think this round will be about the
same that'll be close to 50 percent of
the private work force so when companies
get that federal money those that let
workers go can bring them back at labor
secretary Eugene Scalia told Fox they
need to return the states will want to
carefully administer these programs and
make sure that the people receiving
unemployment benefits are people who
don't have an opportunity at work
unemployment is not available for people
who have been called back to their job
for example and so we'll keep an eye on
that as well but it's got to be tempting
to say no to your old boss since the
extra federal unemployment amounts to 15
bucks an hour in addition to the state
assistance that's a wage many people
don't make at work well there's been a
lot of talk about and debate over the
fact that there will be and there are
many workers who are making more money
on unemployment benefits when you factor
in the extra six hundred dollars than
they would you know working their
regular job the federal government has
made very clear that workers cannot like
quit their jobs because
they want to get you know more money on
unemployment benefits so that's not
allowed though they would not be
eligible for unemployment benefits when
we get into the month of May we have on
Friday rent due for a lot of people
again mortgage payments and all of this
and there's a lot of people who are who
are out of work and still waiting from
employment checks have you heard that
it's getting better that more states are
finally handing out the money
states are definitely working through
their backlogs I think we've seen
evidence of that in the the most recent
jobless claims report states like
Florida and Connecticut so big jumps
last week in last week's topless claims
report in terms of the number of people
that were filing for unemployment
benefits and those are states that have
been operating on sort of the older
technology and it seems like they're
they're working through their their
backlogs but still there are you know
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
people who are waiting for their
unemployment benefits or have not been
able to file for them so so problem I
think states are starting to catch up
them lastly we won't get the monthly
jobs report until a week from this
Friday so May 8th is when we'll find out
the next one what's the expectation for
the unemployment rate rising from March
to April there are all sorts of
different estimates you know some
economists are saying it could approach
great depression levels others are a
little bit more optimistic but the point
is a lot of people were not counted in
the March unemployment rate and so the
April April rate is expected to be much
higher we talking double digits I
wouldn't be surprised to see that all
right Sarah Cheney economics reporter
Wall Street Journal thank you so much
for joining us
thanks so much for having me Dave
[Music]
it's the Perino and star Walt I'll tell
you what podcast dana perino of the five
and foxnews political editor Christina J
SEC the ins and outs of national
politics subscribe and listen now by
going to Fox News podcasts dot-com rate
and review the Fox News rundown on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen it's
time for your fox news commentary Rivera
what's on your mind
first I want to talk about the absolute
delight with which enemies of the
presidency stand the whole bleach fiasco
I think it's instructive I think it
reveals the eager utter willingness to
believe the absolute worst about
President Trump everything he does or
says will be construed by many in the
media and the most evil cartoonish way
possible you know a couple of days now
passed since the whole bleach thing and
I think most have come to the conclusion
that the president's a lot of things but
he's not the dope he surely knows that
bleach is toxic it'll kill you if
ingested I mean the premise is so stupid
drinking or injecting bleach I believe
that most folks with a minimum of half a
brain believed that the president was
being droll and sarcastic I certainly
hope he was pressure on him and the
governor's to reopen the country hang in
there our grim national nightmare almost
over
many states getting ready to ease social
restrictions gradually beginning May
first you know that's a good thing
states reopening many folks that I think
will remain reluctant to go out to
resume their normal lives that many will
restart the old ways absent a cure or a
safe and effective vaccine I think it's
possible that restaurant takeout
shopping online home schooling similar
life changes might be semi-permanent for
a while I think that one of the things
helping us become normal again is
getting small business up and going and
I think it's crucial that regulators and
watchdogs maintain the integrity of the
government's otherwise excellent
small business relief program if tens of
millions of dollars
keep going to fat cats or insiders like
Shake Shack with the LA Lakers or
similar big businesses then the
politicians that steered that money
south
be held accountable big business is
getting a vaccine or a cure ad efforts
are going on in multiple countries
working for a corona vaccine seven of
those trials already being tested on
humans
Oxford University has a vaccine that may
be available they're saying as early as
this September just a few months from
now if only Big Pharma attack rightfully
for their complicity in the opioid
epidemic if they would just suspend
their voracious profit hunger and join
forces to get a vaccine up and moving as
fast as possible to as many people as
possible wouldn't that be nice
so the Oxford team as I said it seems
leading in the potential race for a
vaccine one roadblock though is that
they have no agreement with American
manufacturers right now big pharma based
in America usually many of them they're
insisting on exclusive worldwide rights
to any vaccine that they produce I mean
you would think that this much maligned
industry would do the right thing you
know after the smear that they
rightfully got from the whole opioid
epidemic let them do the right thing
here not insist on profiting from saving
the world
so the nicer the spring weather the more
simmering the impulse to get out and
about restart your life do it reasonably
follow the rules maintain your social
distance wash your hands forget about
hugging or handshakes we're in the final
stretch let's not blow it now I'm
Geraldo Rivera reporting Fox News
you've been listening to the FoxNews
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
[Music]
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes